Salut ! Aujourd'hui j'ai joué à la Valette-du-Var à l'espace belge je ne sais plus quoi.
On vient de terminer.
Comme vous pouvez le constater, les gars sont en train de ranger le matériel
et surtout j'ai eu de la visite.
Je ne vais pas vous le cacher, j'ai eu de la visite.
Je vous fait voir.
Attention !
C'est Cédric !
-Bonjour !
Et là tout le monde se dit: "Mais qui est ce mec en fait ?"
En fait Cédric est le mari, ou le copain ?
-Oui, le petit copain.
Cédric est le petit copain d'Héloïse !
-Bonjour !
Et du coup tout le monde se dit: "Mais c'est qui Héloïse ?"
On ne connait pas ces gens Fabien !
Et si, vous les connaitriez si vous lisiez plus régulièrement les commentaires du Mental Vlog.
Parce que Héloïse est abonné à la chaine.
-C'est ça.
Ca veut dire quoi ces tatouages ?
-Heu...
Non ! Ne dis rien !
Tu sais ce que ça veut dire toi ? La signification ?
-Oui.
Je vous fait voir un truc.
Je peux leur montrer ?
-Oui pas de souci.
Vas-y c'est bon.
Regardez, il a de jolis tatouages magnifiques sur le cou. Tu en as que d'un côté ?
-Oui.
Regardez. Juste ici. Je vous remontre encore une fois.
Ecoute ça me donne une idée. Si tu me permets j'aimerai mentaliser ton chéri Héloïse ?
-Oui.
[rires]
Vous ne l'avez pas vu, mais elle a fait: "Ouais ouais mentalise-le, et alors si tu pouvais faire en sorte qu'il ne laisse plus trainer ses slips s'il te plait..."
J'ai une question quand même. Ca veut dire un mot ou plusieurs mots ?
-C'est un mot.
D'accord. C'est un mot qui a été écrit.
C'est toi qui a choisi ce tatouage là.
C'est ça.
Donc c'est quelque chose qui a du sens pour toi ?
-C'est ça.
Ok.
Alors j'ai plusieurs questions à te poser, tu me réponds sincèrement.
Est-ce que ça a un rapport avec ta personnalité ?
-Oui.
D'accord. Et c'est en lien avec ton vécu.
-C'est ça.
Ok. Et c'est une clé que tu ne veux pas oublier.
Ok, et c'es pour ça que tu as décidé de le marquer dans ta peau.
-C'est ça.
Ok. Ca marche.
En fait je pense à un mot relativement court, en 4 lettres par exemple.
-C'est ça.
Ok.
Je l'ai écrit là.
Je vous le fait voir à vous.
Est-ce que tu peux me dire ce que signifie ce premier tatouage ?
-"Sage".
Le premier tatouage veut dire "sage" ?
-Ok...
Ok c'est bon, j'ai écrit "sage".
-C'est clair. C'est pas mal.
Cool !
Tu savais que tu allais te faire mentaliser en vidéo ou pas ?
Non. On me l'a dit vite fait, mais je n'y croyait pas trop en fait.
[rires]
Et merci d'être venu me découvrir en spectacle.
-Mais merci à toi c'était énorme !
On est passé de YouTube au réel.
Ca vous a plu ?
-Ah oui c'était énorme !
Cool !
-C'est intriguant.
-C'est fort !
Et ça a duré 1H30.
-Oui.
Ils ont osé de passer de la chaine YouTube au spectacle, faites comme eux, vous pouvez oser.
-Allez-y, j'étais réticent mais allez-y !
Ah oui c'est vrai, tu étais réticent ?
-Ouais je ne crois pas trop à ce genre de tour, mais au final...
quand on voit ça en direct c'est énorme !
Allez-y !
-Courrez le voir !
Merci beaucoup les amis ! Merci ! Merci !
Abonnez-vous à la chaine YouTube c'est très important.
Vous pouvez aussi venir me voir en spectacle, commentez comme Héloïse
et après on peut discuter.
Abonnez vous à la chaine et rendez-vous demain, à 17H pour le prochain Mental Vlog.
Ciao !